Rene is with us Rene is in Missouri hi
Rene how are you hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve
how can I help I have a question for you
my husband and I we're on baby step two
and we have about $25,000 in debt and
we're thinking about refinancing our
house
to pay that off why kind of want your
input on that why what's that why well
it just seems like the little things
every month what we're paying and that
are just like chipping away and we can't
like really get ahead or save for
anything because you're not really
paying off your debt you understand that
you're just moving it right but we have
a lot of equity in our house yeah but
you're moving it
you're still in debt yes you just change
the name of the debt and chose not to
deal with it so what's your household
income seventeen thousand okay how long
you been working on this um
about 18 months we've paid off about 17
to 18 I would not know I think you're
running it on a speed about 50% on
tightening up your budget I think you
guys need to the two of you need to work
together look at the budget very
carefully every single month write it
out and stick to it I I think you're
doing ish you're doing an you're not
doing a bad job you're just not doing a
good job you should have paid off more
making 70000 than you have and 25,000
shouldn't be an insurmountable task
making 70,000 and so how much is your
house payment about 1100 that's not out
of line okay let me kids who've you got
we have to okay husband
is not on board all the way well okay
maybe so yeah okay all right so
sometimes there's an anchor while you're
trying to get this boat moving you try
it's like you know I tried to ski one of
the kids this summer and I forgot to put
the anchor in you know and it the boat
was just dragging this anchor you know
and it feels like there's something
holding this thing back it ought to be
going faster than it is and and I can't
figure out what it is exactly I was
looking for it in the numbers but it's
not in the numbers it's in the spouse so
um yeah just sit down with him and you
guys readjust and recommit and turn up
the fire on both of you - gizelle
intensity level you've got it down there
at rabbit level let's kick it on up -
gizelle level and get it moving and cut
your lifestyle down and a commitment to
not going out to eat and not going on
vacation and beans and rice rice and
beans and we're gonna work extra and
we're gonna sell stuff and we're
freaking getting out of debt man that's
what you got to do and when you do that
when you kind of get that thing going in
your voice that's when everything
changes hey thanks for the call you know
what's weird is guys that on doing this
for 30 years we've seen antidotal II and
with actual data points in our research
with our team with our tribe out here
that um it's weird it's because I'm a
math nerd and this drives me bananas the
numbers don't predict your income versus
the debt you have don't predict whether
you get out of debt what predictor is
how pissed off you are how intense you
are how sacrificial you're willing to
live and you can't really put like
quantify that it's not like a number you
can put on it but when somebody gets
that thing in their voices like you know
and they're ready to kill it that's the
ones that are getting out of that I mean
it can be a single mom making 18,000 and
she'll whip a hundred thousands but you
know cuz ain't no stopping this chick
and then I talked to somebody making a
hundred and ten they're like do we
so you need to get there and it's not
getting do with the numbers it's got to
do with how are you sick and tired of
being sick and tired are the two of you
on the same page if you got your every
dollar budget out are you dialed in have
you got this roar going are you gonna
get after it baby you sell so much stuff
the kids think they're next the dogs
named eBay and the cats named Craig's
List baby
we are moving some stuff around here
we're not living like this anymore it's
not happening man
you got to move something and that's the
only time it moves that's really what
happens in your life everywhere if you
really want deep transformation and
change in some area of your life
it requires that kind of passionate
focus a visceral reaction to saving your
marriage a visceral reaction to causing
your kids to straighten up and fly right
a visceral reaction to shifting your
career a visceral reaction to changing
the way you handle money
this transformation stuff is not
quantifiable with math it's all about
game on baby